[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning good morning please put
your phones away no photography and I am
asking State Police that is present if
you see someone with their phone you
please ask them to leave no phones so
from this point forward please
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
check there we go good morning we're
going to ask everyone take your seats
the family is about five minutes away
and then we will start so if you could
start to take your seats thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
right on - I don't
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
while two bottles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
on piano the legend
Richard small
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
walk in the light come on this is a
church service slip your voices
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
see
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
merci
[Applause]
oh Jesus
[Music]
put your voices together
it's a beautiful hide
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
see the syllabi
[Music]
[Music]
is bill with babies
[Music]
come on somebody puts a hand together
like you in a good old sanctified toast
[Music]
please come women dr. Robert Smith
I am your host family friend mr. Charles
HL is the third senior pastor of greater
grace temple standing next to me is
reverend dr. Robert Smith jr. he is the
pastor of the renowned New Bethel
Missionary Baptist Church Franklin
family church it is our task to move
this service along and to honor the
wishes of the family they have outlined
in order of service and we will follow
to the best of our ability you should
have your programs if you don't they are
being passed out as we speak if they
have not already been passed out there
are few changes on the program we will
try to keep things moving we will ask
everyone that is participating on the
program you don't need to give honor to
me or to dr. Smith or to anybody on the
stage or the pulpit you can give honor
to Jesus beginning your remarks to this
family
I will ask everyone for today we have
plenty programs y'all just amen some of
them gonna end up on eBay so just just
calm it make sure you keep this as a
keepsake
amen amen it's a little time to get in
here but I believe the Queen wouldn't
have had it any other way
it is our task to move this service
along we will ask everyone that is
participating on the in this service on
today if you would be so kind as to keep
your remarks brief those that are
reading scriptures we will ask you to do
that those of you that are praying
prayers we're good to do that this is
going to be a lengthy service amen you
cannot celebrate the life of an icon a
legacy a mother and aunt a grandmother
in a couple hours we're going to do our
best not to waste time but we want to
take the necessary time to honor this
great woman of God I know that you have
been standing for quite a while but I'm
going to ask you one last time everyone
except the family this family has shared
their mother their grandmother their
aren't their cousin with the entire
world let us all stand and thank them
for sharing her with us
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going to ask at this time if my wife
lady Chrisette Ellis the first lady of
this house would come and bring to you a
welcome and a greetings please receive
lady Cosette Ellis and welcome to
greater grace temple we are praying for
the Franklin family you've lost a mother
grandmother and aunt and the world has
lost the Queen thank you for trusting us
in a final farewell for the iconic miss
Aretha Franklin
the Queen was ordinary and extraordinary
and has attracted the same all over the
world people have come to pay tribute to
a once-in-a-lifetime talent whose voice
was the soundtrack of our lives to
celebrate it and the uncelebrated dance
to the queen's music clean house to the
queen's music laugh cry make corn bread
and greens to her music break up make up
dream dreams to her music
the queen of cold soul sang to our soul
one beat one sound there was something
she made us feel Aretha was real the
motor in this city the Queen of Soul
blasting on the radio
traveling the highways and byways of
life we found the freeway of love thank
you thank you miss Aretha Franklin it's
been quite a ride pink Cadillacs rolling
we can't quit till we get to the other
side god bless you
I will call now for the following
individuals to come in this order we
will have the prayer of comfort dr. al
branch we will have the scriptures of
comfort the Old Testament Bishop TD
jakes the New Testament pastor Solomon
Ken lock and the song bishop pa Brooks
after they have concluded we will
receive miss faith heal with a musical
selection let's receive these in this
order
tell me not in mournful numbers life is
but an empty dream for the soul is dead
that slumbers and things are not what
they seem
life is real life is earnest and the
grave is not its goal dust thou art to
dust returnest was not spoken of the
soul God of love and peace we give you
glory honor and praise on this day your
name is holy and we celebrate your
goodness toward us you Lord have brought
us from a mighty long way our souls like
a wreath us look back and wonder how we
made it over over heels and mountains
through dark and dismal valleys you
brought us Lord we bring to you our
struggles we are weak but you are strong
where we are broken Lord put us back
together again but we are cold and
insensitive warm our spirits we stand in
need of your blessings fix us repair us
revive us today Lord we thank you for
the life and legacy of Aretha Louise
Franklin thank you for giving us such a
precious gift in Aretha she was a
treasure from a treasure and a treasure
surrounded by treasures you gave us
Reverend Clarence Levon Franklin his
golden voice and Theological genius and
we thank you you then gave us Aretha
whom we now celebrate as the queen of
soul thank you Lord for Aretha whose
generous gifts fed the hungry clothe the
naked and sheltered the homeless who
touched so many lives the world over
from Pope's and
presidents even to the least and alas
whose music captivated our minds and
hearts with rapturous rhythm and
life-giving lyrics who started with us
and stayed with us and stuck with us
through stick thick and fan good times
and bad thank you Lord for Aretha she
was first detroit's then America's then
the world thank you Lord for Aretha she
was strong in her spirit pure in her
heart generous and her giving sweet in
her compassion calm and her demeanor
gentle in her touch powerful in her
embrace
thank you for Aretha she was wise in her
advice bold in her speech classy in her
walk
stylish in her apparel faithful in her
service loving to her family loyal to
her faith and submissive to her God
thank you Lord for Aretha she was a
bright and shining star she was an image
of hope larger than life she was a
soldier
a trooper an encourager a good and
faithful servant thank you Lord for
Aretha she charmed us she thrilled us
she entertained us she inspired us
she motivated us she helped us she hope
us she blessed us one at all thank you
Lord for Aretha Lord you gave us a queen
a true queen royalty at its best and we
thank you we pray now for the Franklin
family grant them your comfort and peace
give them strength for this hour heal
their wounded spirits and mend their
broken hearts give unto them beauty for
Ashes and the oil of joy for mourning
and the garment of praise for the spirit
of heaviness we pray for all of those
worked with sang with and traveled with
Aretha through all of these many years
we pray for New Bethel Baptist Church
and pastor Smith we pray for Detroit and
for the faithful fans and followers
throughout the entire world we pray for
this church greater grace temple and
Bishop Ellis we pray for our eulogist
dr. jasper williams feed him that he
might feed us be his strength his
inspiration and his joy we pre fall in
dissuading congregation every person
here that you would meet each of us at
the point of our knee and then lord when
it's all over here when we have some our
last song and prayed our last prayer
take us to that land where we'll never
grow old that land where the wicked will
cease their troubling and the weary
shall be at last where all of the saints
of the ages will sit at his feet and be
blessed although we must be it farewell
to the queen of soul thank you Lord for
being our King of Kings who will be with
us forever and ever hallelujah and a man
good morning Church that's it good
morning Church somebody put your hands
together and help me praise our God this
is what the Franklin middle class all by
herself has touched the world each of us
in our own way amazing individual classy
beyond comparison and yet an earthiness
about her that is undeniable ubiquitous
in her gifting showing up everywhere
from the palaces in England singing for
the Queen to popping up in the backseat
of a car in the middle of a commercial
Aretha was everywhere she was classy
enough to sing on the most prominent
stages in the world but she was homegirl
enough to make potato salad and fry some
chicken in a class all by herself in
1989 the first time my wife and I had
gone to the Grammys we had the privilege
of going at the right place at the right
time Luciano Pavarotti was supposed to
perform that night he got ill and could
not perform and guess who took his place
miss Aretha Franklin with class and
dignity to the mic and begin to sing in
the place of Pavarotti until we forgot
he was on the program at all
she son de Nesle Domo which means none
shall sleep and she did it with finesse
and power and clarity and even though it
appears that she is laying in a box the
song is true none shall sleep she is not
here she has risen
I stand on behalf of the Potter's House
of my lovely wife that has joined me to
publicly thank her for her service she
ministered for us at megafest a
friendship evolved every time I got a
chance to go where she was I was there I
had the privilege of hanging out in the
back having fun laughing and talking
with her she shall be missed I asked I
was asked to read the Old Testament text
many people do not realize that the
Bible at its core is a love story and
that walking with God at his core is a
relationship it is a relationship that
starts out where we come to him and if
we are prayerful and if we are careful
when things get tough and difficult as
it did for Aretha the God that we came
to will also come for us
Aretha the PK the preacher's kid came to
Jesus and when she got in trouble he
came to her their relationship was a
love story salvo Solomon 2 & 1 I am the
Rose of Sharon and the lily of the
valleys as a lily among thorns so is my
love among the daughters as a apple tree
among the trees of the wood so is my
beloved among the sons i sat down under
his shadow with great delight and his
fruit was sweet to my taste he brought
me to the banqueting house
and Hispanic or Fermi was love
stay with me with flagons comfort me
with apples
I am sick of love his left hand is under
my head and his right hand doth embrace
me I charge you o ye daughters of
Jerusalem by the rolls and by the hands
of the field that she started up nor
awake my love till he be pleased this is
what happened the voice of my beloved
behold he cometh leaping upon the
mountains skipping upon the heels now
beloved is like a roar young heart the
whole he standeth behind our wall he
looketh forth at the windows showing
himself through the lattice the other
night my beloved spake and said unto me
rise up my love my fair one and come
away
for long no the winter is past the rain
is over and gone rise of my beloved and
come away come bow and counted word gird
with my mighty sword let my people be
blessed
let thy word have success Holy Spirit
descend in the Gospel of Luke chapter 11
evidently the disciples had sense and
could see that the landscape of Jesus's
ministry was littered with prayer and so
a question was raised Lord teach us to
pray Jesus taught them to pray in this
manner you don't have to pray exactly
like this but this is a great model for
prayer when you pray our Father which
are thou in heaven hallow would be thy
name thy kingdom come Thy will be done
on earth as it is in heaven give us
today our daily bread and forgive us our
debts as we forgive our debtors
lead us not into temptation but deliver
us from evil for thine is the kingdom
the power and the glory forever and ever
let every born-again believer shall a
man
let the church say man
[Music]
King David wrote to the 139 Psalm to
acknowledge that in every aspect of his
life God of the very substance of
everything that he had and everything
that he became and so I believe this
Psalm speaks from the heart of even
Aretha I shall read at the 139th Psalm
with selected verses from the message
Bible Lord I am an open book to you even
from a distance you know what I'm
thinking I'm never out of your sight
you know everything I'm going to say
before I start the first sentence I look
behind me and you're there then up ahead
you are there too with your reassuring
presence coming and going this is much
too wonderful for me where shall I go
from thy presence to be out of thy sight
if I climb to the sky
you're there if I go underground you're
there if I flew on morning wings to the
far western horizon you'd find me in a
moment you're already there waiting at
night I'm immersed in the light it's a
fact darkness isn't dark to you night
and day darkness and light they're all
the same to you dear Lord oh yes
you shaped me first inside then out you
formed me in my mother's womb I thank
you dear Lord you are astounding and
amazing
I am marvelously made body and soul Lord
I worship in adoration what a creation
you know me inside and out you know
every part of my body you know exactly
how was I was made limb by limb how I
was formed from nothing into something
like an open book you watched me grow
from conception to birth all the stages
of my life were spread out before you
the days of my life
all prepared before I even lived one day
dear God whom I worship let me rise in
the morning and live always with you in
Jesus name
[Music]
hello Stella beretta Rita
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you didn't know to take you to Jesus
you know it now when you walk across
floors that you did not scrub and you go
through doors you didn't open turn
around
scrub some floors open some doors in a
world where there's no desire for heaven
and no fear of hell
the one question left is will you leave
the world better than you found it and
certainly we can say that the Queen has
left the world better than she found
[Music]
I told the bishop this is my first and
last time up you know your name and you
know what you only do
folk no you don't your name wouldn't be
on the program says an only the somatic
you're not calling you talking about you
get up do what you got to do if you
don't have found out some about the
bishop working with him today he can
walk fast and most me and run if you're
coming up at the wrong time he will get
up and sit you down because he's not
just a bishop
he's the apodictic Pope please come
where your name appears on the program
[Music]
good morning I'm Mike Duggan I have the
honor to be the Mara Detroit and for the
last two weeks Detroit has been the
center of annum over whelming emotional
outpouring with the loss of our
cherished daughter Aretha Franklin and
for longtime Detroiters that emotional
connection goes back even before Aretha
to her father Reverend CL Franklin one
of Detroit in America's great civil
rights leaders Reverend Franklin was
chief organizer of the Detroit Walk to
Freedom on June 23rd 1963 a hundred
thousand Detroiters marched down
Woodward Avenue led by dr. Martin Luther
King and Reverend Franklin walking
arm-in-arm in Detroit's largest civil
rights event and at the end of that
march at Cobo Hall in Detroit dr. King
delivered his first I have a dream
speech two months before the historic
speech in Washington DC and so as I
watched this week it's tens of thousands
of people lined up outside the Charles
Wright museum blocks long lines waiting
to pay their final respects to Aretha
Franklin I thought back to those long
lines on Woodward behind Reverend CEO
Franklin 55 years ago in thought the
Franklin family has had a huge impact on
the city Detroit for more than a half a
century
we all know the nunnery that got a new
musical start right here in Detroit at
the new Bethel Baptist Church Gospel
Choir was making her first recordings by
the time she was 14 and in each of her
17 top-ten hits each time she soared it
felt like the people of Detroit soared
with her because she never lost her
connection to our city and of course
along with the successes she had in her
life she also suffered real tragedy and
when you listened to the raw emotional
power of that extraordinary voice you
could feel both great joy and great loss
when Aretha Franklin sang it felt like
the voice of Detroit didn't it which I'm
sure is why every place I've gone the
past two weeks
all I get asked is what is Detroit gonna
do to honor Aretha Franklin and I want
to talk about that today because as we
talk to those closer and her family one
of the themes that kept coming up was
that MS Franklin loved the Detroit River
that she lived her last months in the
riverfront apartments that she seemed to
draw a spiritual power from the
is you had to drive up to pine knob an
hour away the beautiful facility will
wasn't accessible to this community and
Mary Jung said Detroit is the center of
music in Michigan we're gonna have our
own outdoor concert setting and so he
went and took an abandoned barge dock
site on Shan Avenue in the riverfront
and he said that's where Detroit's going
to have outdoor concerts now I went to
that first concert season in 1985 it was
basically a stage at a bunch of blankets
on a hill right that's the way it
started but even then it's felts that
fell special cuz it was ours but over
the next five years mayor young built an
amphitheater they're gonna accommodate
six thousand people in a beautifully
landscaped Park that was an attraction
to the city and with the leadership of
shahe DeMaio see shame Park has hosted
many of America's great entertainers
Stevie Wonder and Jack White Earth Wind
& Fire Diana Ross
Run DMC BB King Ray Charles and so many
others but the single largest event ever
held was the 30th year anniversary of
shane park August 22nd 2015 and the
performer that evening was of course
Aretha Franklin
and what makes Shan Park truly unique is
we've kept to the original mission that
even with all those world-class
performers half of our concerts are
either free at low-cost ticket so it's a
place that belongs to all Detroiters and
those concerts are now drawing nearly a
hundred thousand concert goers a year
and anybody that was at last night's
event knows it is now one of the finest
outdoor music venues in the United
States and so I met with President
Brenda Jones and talked to my partners
on Detroit City Council and today it is
with their strong and enthusiastic
support that I can tell you that on
Tuesday I will be sending City Council a
proposal to rename shame Park
our beautiful waterfront jewel will be a
Reetha Franklin Park
and when performers from generations to
come from around the world come here
they'll be reminded that they are
performing at the home of the Queen of
Soul god bless you
and the mayor just got reelected
[Applause]
good afternoon to everyone I would like
to ask I am Detroit city council
president Brenda Jones and I would like
to ask my colleagues to please stand my
colleagues of Detroit City Council we
follow the mayor with a resolution
requesting the renaming of Shame Park to
a wreath of Franklin Park this
resolution will be presented and passed
on Tuesday tomorrow next week and also
will follow is an ordinance which is law
to ensure that Shayne Park will remain
Aretha Franklin Park
Alicia what's world-famous but she was
more than just a singer or a recording
artist her minute Aryan efforts
larger-than-life heart and silent
generosity will forever be remembered
whether you've met her personally
I just heard her distinguished voice on
many of her hits queen or with touched
us all from the boardroom to the plant
floor from the east side to the west
side she United us all under a banner of
our espec teeth respect of all Reaper
received many different awards and
recognitions she texts me and indicated
the greatest was having a street Aretha
Franklin Wayne named for her in the city
she loves and I am humbled to have led
that effort to honor Aretha and give her
her flowers while she was living I am
also proud to present to the family the
highest honor restored by the Detroit
City Council a resolution in memoriam
and I have one for all of her sons in
the interest of time I will not read the
resolution but I am pleased to inform
you that a copy of this resolution will
be placed in the archives of the city of
Detroit and Aretha Franklin's life in
her legacy will live on and on in the
city of Detroit and also there are many
things about Aretha that I displayed in
this testimonial resolute
In Memoriam and it reads about where as
part of her professional accomplishments
she was equally content with the joy she
received from those she cherished
including family and friends the mother
of four signs of wreaths are created and
neutral connections with loved ones all
around the world and most certainly left
a lasting impression and the hearts and
minds of those she knew personally in
many that she never met the Detroit diva
performed her final hometown show on
June 10th 2017 headlining the Detroit
Music weekend festival at the Music Hall
and whereas we wish to honor Rita
Franklin with the city's most
prestigious displays of appreciation
which is a secondary street officially
renaming a portion of Madison Avenue
Aretha Franklin way which now occupies
the intersection between Whittle and
Rush Street
[Applause]
now therefore be resolved that the
Detroit City Council joins with family
and friends and family and honoring the
life and the legacy of Aretha Franklin
she will be greatly missed
in her contributions to the world will
live on and on
god bless you god bless Aretha Franklin
and all that she contributed to the
world international thank you
[Applause]
putting I'm riffing Joanne Watson Aretha
Franklin was my dear friend she loved
Detroit she loved her family she loves
her father especially she loved New
Bethel Baptist Church or she grew up
singing and supporting the Ministry of
Reverend dr. C L Franklin arethe also
loved the civil rights movement
she loved the human rights movement she
loved the women's rights movement she
loved the environmental justice movement
she loved the reparations movement
whenever I go to a reparation of the
meeting somewhere in the nation she'd
say Joanne tell him to bring me back a
check she asked me to attend the
premiere of Selma with her in New York
City what a blessing to be there and she
whispered to me in New York
I thought you here so you could
represent my father she never relied on
anyone else to tell her story she wrote
her own script she handed her own
business she understood had a real power
without raising her voice she was paid
in advance when she performed she would
insist there be no air conditioned if
she was to sing she refused to be
extorted or disrespected she planned and
paid for her own Christmas parties she
planned and paid for her own birthday
parties come home somebody with
exquisite top-of-the-line
entertainment in first-class cuisine
when she first received a diagnosis and
nothing when a medical procedure
December 2nd 2010 she asked me to host a
prayer vigil for her at City Hall and
she personally selected the ministers
who were standing in front of the spirit
of Detroit and she wanted a Miss Fanny
Tata to tell them they were only to pray
and not to talk to the press my mama she
was the world's queen an invaluable
musical treasure a humanitarian a
daddy's girl filled with amazing grace
but more than anything else she was the
quintessential epitome of the greatness
and on this authenticity of the city of
Detroit she would ride the streets of
Detroit taking note of people who had
special needs
quietly dispensing donations and she
also never took her eyes off the
Reverend
after CEO Franklin signed on Linden in
Philadelphia or father's plaque in the
Reverend dr. Co Franklin Park I'd get
those midnight calls and take Joann you
people had to put my daddy sign up again
whether I was in office or retired she
was in a class by herself she will
forever be our angel queen Aretha Louise
Franklin forever
I believe that the federal government
would do well to have a postage stamp
honoring our Queen Aretha Franklin honor
Rita in the same way she always honored
us she's now queen mother as she has
been risen to the ancestral realm ruling
knowing that the Lord is going to say
well done thou good and faithful servant
that has been faithful over a few things
I will make you master over many thank
you God for her life thank you God for
her song thank you God for her service
thank you God for her royal highness I
clean a Rita Franklin
well good afternoon I want to start by
thanking the Franklin family it's an
honor that you had invited me to come
speak and to bring my wife Sue and on
behalf of every citizen of the state of
Michigan our thoughts and prayers are
with all of you
Aretha was a special person to the state
of Michigan to all of us in the state
many of you know how many awards you
want and she deserved every single one
of those but I'm gonna mention an honor
you may not have ever heard of but it
reflects our feelings for her and it's
gets shown in the outpouring and love
and support you've seen this week for
all these wonderful events back in the
80s
under governor Blanchard the Michigan
Department of Natural Resources actually
declared are--those voice was a natural
resource of the state of Michigan
[Applause]
that's something special folks that
strikes you right in the heart the other
part of it though as a Michigan der I
thought I'd share something about what
the Queen of Soul really meant to all of
us and the thing is the Queen of Soul is
not a title it's a feeling it's an
emotion and it means different things
and I just thought I'd share three of
those very quickly with you because we
have so many wonderful people to talk
and sing first if you looked at it she
had a god-given voice a talent a musical
skill that people on a dream of but she
did more than that
she took not just the triumphs of her
life she took the challenges and the
tragedies and brought a special humanity
to her words to her voice to her music
that most musicians would only dream to
have and it's something that Starks is
all in our heart and soul and I'll give
you a simple case and our family will
have family outings we'll have friends
over and all of a sudden I never know
why they're spontaneous singing they
start singing and you want number one on
the hit list is respect and you know who
the leader of the chorus is my wife Sue
and it's wonderful it comes out when
everyone gets fired up and I can tell
you when it's done though if I'm feeling
brave I will suggest to her that she
leave the recordings to Aretha and the
performances to Aretha but it has
transformed lives the second thing is
it's not just about entertaining it's
not just about making us feel better she
used her presence her voice her music to
make the world a better place the work
she did for civil rights the work she
did for women's rights that was making a
profound difference in our society and
we should be proud and that's why she's
the king of soul also finally one thing
to share with you
is if you think about our lives we're on
this world for a very short time if we
live a good life and most of us will
well have the opportunity to say we made
a positive impact on our children our
family our friends our neighbors our
community potentially even the world and
we should be proud of that but aretha
brought something different
Aretha Franklin the Queen of Soul
brought something bigger now stop and
think it's not just gonna be us that are
gonna benefit from what she's given us
already or all the people of Michigan
all the people the world that are living
today Aretha Franklin is timeless her
gift will continue giving for not just
five tens fifty years it will be a
hundred two hundred five hundred years
that the message he's sending inner
music inner spirit and bringing humanity
these things will make a difference
those are incredible gifts and we should
be so proud and I will tell you that the
people of Detroit the people of Michigan
have a very special place in your heart
and we will remember these gifts in so
many different ways so god bless you
Aretha and to the Franklin family thank
you so much
[Applause]
please receive it this time the music
ministry of Ariana Grande
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I've got the I've got to apologize
because I have to brush up my 28-year
daughter tells me dead you are old at 16
when I saw ariana grande on the program
I thought that was a new something at
Taco Bell girl let me give you all your
respect did y'all enjoy this icon she's
an icon herself come on make a feel of
it great a very simple the city of
babies please receive one of the
greatest voices for the urban community
[Applause]
not them yet this is one of the greatest
voices not many of the greatest voices
we're going to adjust the program
quickly at this time this man has spoken
out he stood on the front line he has
been a man for the people of the people
please receive Reverend Al Sharpton
[Applause]
Thank You Bishop to the Franklin family
and to all of us gathered Aretha
Franklin was not only an unparalleled
artist she was a civil rights activist
and freedom fighter it is easy to
celebrate the gifts that God gives it is
more difficult when someone uses those
gifts in ways that enhances humanity
Aretha Franklin was given special gifts
but she used it in a special way and she
would not want us to celebrate her
without talking about she stood for
something she never shamed us she never
disgraced us she never made us make
excuses for her she represented the best
in our community and she fought for our
community until the end
I first met miss Franklin when I was a
teenager I've become youth director of
New York operation breadbasket and she
would come to the strategy meetings with
Reverend Jackson and I would hear the
stories of how when dr. Martin Luther
King could make payroll Harry Belafonte
and Aretha Franklin went on a leaven
City tour to raise money for Martin
Luther King lot of others hang up dr.
King's photo but Aretha went and raised
money and gave it and worked free her
daddy March with dr. King and she never
stopped supporting as the years went by
and I developed National Action Network
and she would call my radio show and
have me come to her affairs she called
me one day she said Remy I want to send
you something I said yes ma'am she said
what's your home address and she said it
about three days later I got a check
made out Nash Action Network signed by
Aretha Franklin I saw about a month
later I said you know I was so blown
away I grew up looking up to you did i
frame that [ __ ] she said boy don't you
have a copy machine
[Applause]
she said you don't know how I am with my
bank accounts you better catch that
chicken but all of her life she
supported the causes she was a feminist
before feminism was popular she was a
civil rights activist when it wasn't
popular
she gave us pride and she gave us a
regal bar to reach and that's why we all
here we don't all agree on everything
but we agree on Aretha and she fought
she fought for everybody I remember when
we were used to picking Charles Williams
and all of us jumping on the record
industry she said now y'all leave Clive
Davis along he's one of the good ones
she loved Clive and said we got to
remember what happened to the Irish and
what happened to Jews and what happened
to blacks and that is why we remember
her legacy because she sang a song for
all of us
she was the soundtrack of the civil
rights movement if you track where we
are you can follow where Rita had us
that's why when I look at her and James
Brown whose daughter's here and others
who paid a price that opened the door
but never forgot where they came from
she was rooted in the black church she
was bathed in the black church and she
took the black church downtown and made
folks that didn't know what the Holy
Ghost was shout in the middle of a
concert you never saw her perform
without her doing gospel cuz she never
was a one to forget where she came from
and that's why we give her this great
home going we thank her for what she did
with dr. King we thank her for what
she's done with Reverend Jackson
thank her for what she's done with all
of us and that is why you know the other
Sunday on my show I've misspelled
respect and a lot of y'all lot of y'all
corrected me now I want y'all to help me
correct President Trump to teach him
what it means
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and I say that because when word had
went out that Miss Franklin pass Trump
said sheeps to work for me no she used
to perform for you she worked for us
[Applause]
retha never took orders from nobody but
God so Rita as you get your rest my
mother passed about six years ago
President Clinton my mother and I had a
deal she said I'll meet you on the other
side you live the way you supposed to
and I'll see you in heaven I said well
mom did they tell me there is nobody's
in heaven just spirits how am I gonna
know you I know our sons how will I know
it she said tell you you meet me at the
exchange counter I said exchange counter
what is what kind of exchange counter
she said well right after you get
through the golden gates there's an
exchange counter that's where you hand
in your cross to pick up your crime we
watched Aretha bear her cross down here
she had to sing with a broken heart she
had to work when she didn't get paid
she was a black woman in a white man's
world she bared her cross she fought a
good faith now it's time to crown the
queen I'll see you at exchange town when
you cannot hand in your cross ain't no
cats over there Reba hand in your cross
and pick up your crown
[Music]
as I take my seat I've been asked to
read this
[Music]
[Applause]
don't don't don't do that
[Applause]
cuz I only have five minutes and y'all
to make me going to something else dear
friends and family of Aretha Michelle
and I extend our heartfelt sympathies to
all of those who gathered in Detroit and
we join you in remembering and
celebrating the life of the Queen of
Soul from a young age Aretha Franklin
rocked the world of anyone who had the
pleasure of hearing a voice whether
bringing people together through
thrilling intersections of John use or
advancing important causes through the
power of song a Rita's work reflected
the very best of the American story
in all of its hope and heart its
boldness and its unmistakable beauty in
the example she set both as an artist
and a citizen Aretha embodied those most
revered virtues of forgiveness and
reconciliation while the music she made
captured some of our deepest human
desires namely affection and respect and
through her voice our own voice
Aretha lifted those of millions
empowering and inspiring the vulnerable
the downtrodden and everyone who may
have just needed a little love Aretha
truly was one-of-a-kind and as you pay
tribute know we'll be saying a little
prayer for you and we'll be thinking of
all of are--those loved ones in the days
and weeks to come
sincerely Barack Obama 44th President of
the United States
please receive Motown crate Detroit song
mr. Smokey Robinson had levi stubbs The
Four Tops funeral a few years ago here
smokey had all of the Motown recording
artists to come in the stand at the
casket and I looked in I saw Acton
walkers and and gray hair and no hair
and I kept looking at them and looking
at smokey and I said I want what you
drinking and he give Smokey Robinson a
hand he'll be followed by The Clark
Sisters some about eight years old and
I'm outside and I'm playing with my
neighborhood friends second and fee
being a lien we shooting marbles coz it
was at a time when kids were able to
play outside you know so I don't even
know if voice you know what that is
anymore
but Richard Ross another one of our
friends came around and there's a new
guy with him and introduced him he said
this is Cecil so we all you know like
boys do we started playing and after a
while we weren't around to see Cecil's
new house cuz they had just moved to
Detroit from Buffalo and we go in and
we're walking around the house look at
it and I'm seeing stuff that I had never
seen cuz but nearly like my house cuz
you know somebody broke in my house they
better be bringing something
but uh anyway we're walking around a
house and and I hear music the piano
being played and this voice that sounds
like a little girl singing and I go and
look in that room and I see you and
you're there and you're singing and that
was my first meeting and my first sight
of you and from that moment on almost we
have been so so close and so tight and I
didn't know especially this soon that I
was going to be having to say goodbye to
you or farewell or whatever we've seen
everybody all the people that I
mentioned earlier pass on and go and we
talked about it many times how we were
the two who were who were left out of
all our neighborhood friends we were the
longest ones we weren't the only two
left but we were the longest ones so now
my longest friend has gone home and you
want to be with our father like we all
have to do one of these days and I know
you're up there and you're celebrating
with your family and with all of our
neighborhood friends who have gone and
you're going to be one of the featured
voices and the choir of angels because
you know you'd have to be
I also know you know I've been on the
road and I've been watching the
celebration of your life from everywhere
and I've been doing interviews from
everywhere from all over the world that
the last one I did was from Brazil and
the station that I was talking on
covered all of South America so the
world is celebrating you and the world
is mourning you and the world is going
to miss you and I know that I'm gonna
miss you so much because I miss our
talks and we would talk for hours
sometimes just talking about really
anything we want to talk about or
nothing and the last conversation we had
you were telling me that you give or do
your movie and you want to know who I
wanted to play me so I told you I was
going to leave that up to you cuz you
you you were so special and a while back
we did a mini-series on The Temptations
life and for that movie I I did a school
I did the school for the movie and I had
to write a song for Melvin Franklin who
was another one of our close close
people and I'm sure he won't mind if I
sing a little bit of it for you because
it fits you so perfectly in my life
really gonna miss you it's really gonna
be different with
- for the rest of my life gonna be
thinking about you ah miss you my buddy
ah miss you my friend know that my love
for you will never end will never love
you forever
[Applause]
[Music]
he said let's go to church let me just
say this this is on behalf of me and my
sisters
miss Franklin has just been a jewel to
us the world is watching many of you are
from all over the world but I want to
hear from Motown tonight let's salute
the Queen tonight and with Detroit can
we salute the Queen so many memories of
miss Franklin and we would never will
forget that day we performed on the
Grammys with her
he was so cordial to as she said you
know y'all my girl and it was just so
many great memories of course Karen not
talk but it's okay
it's okay
but she loved Karen and I just want to
say let's continue to keep the Queen in
our hearts twinky wrote a song says it's
my living in vain
it's my giving in vain it's my praying
in vain is my fascinated by am I wasting
my time can the club be rewind no of
course not it's not all in vain
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sisters Northwest Detroit Sorrento
Aretha Franklin lived on Sorrento long
before blacks to live in Grosse Pointe
and Bloomfield Hills and Birmingham we
couldn't go out of town but we could
going out of Drive put your hands
together one more time for The Clark
Sisters
[Applause]
and this is our Samson is coming with
the acknowledgments and condolences
receive her at this time
[Applause]
to the family of Aretha L Franklin Laura
and I are deeply saddened by the loss of
the Queen of Soul Aretha Franklin our
hearts ache for you and our prayers are
with you
Aretha was a woman of achievement with a
deep character and a loving heart she
made important and lasting contributions
to American music with her gospel
inspired style and distinctive voice her
remarkable talent helped shape our
nation's artistic and cultural heritage
and in 2005 it was my privilege to honor
her with our country's highest civilian
award the Presidential Medal of Freedom
I am proud to have met Aretha and am
grateful that her music will continue to
bring joy to millions for generations to
come
as you remember an honor Aretha 's life
may the almighty comfort you in your
grief and sustain you during this
difficult time Laura and I send our
heartfelt sympathy may God bless you
George W Bush
[Applause]
the family would like to recognize and
offer a special thank you to the
following friends and medical
professionals who went above and beyond
the call of duty to offer their services
and comfort to miss Franklin dr. Donald
Weaver and dr. Don John Barnwell DMC dr.
Phillip Phillips hermanos dr. Manish
Shah and Ashima Gullo Ohio State the
nursing staff of the DMC and Hospice of
Michigan
Connie Robin and Laurie Hughes
caregivers friends Beverly Bradley
Dolores Yancey Karen Karen Bootsie Smith
and Angela Mason Wendelin Quinn
publicist tracy Jordan Sirius XM radio a
Curtis Farrow Brian
Dickens Bishop Charles a cellist the
third and staff Alexis Wiley and staff
of mayor's office
captain Conway petty DPD zarifa Coleman
George Hamilton and staff of the Charles
H stripe Museum of african-american
history
Swanson funeral homes Ford Motor Company
tribute hosts and sponsors shahida Mayu
see Shane park Chemical Bank judge Greg
Mathis Isaiah Thomas
Marvin Beatty Greektown casino minion
more donna Brazile Yolanda caraway teen
of llinois and Leigh adultery friends
Harley brown Ron Moulton and Linda
Solomon photography graphic designer
Deon Yates and Linda Davis of R and L
color graphics lastly to all of the
teams of Aretha's angels who work
tirelessly to execute the celebration of
her life and legacy all of your acts of
kindness will never be forgotten
if we have omitted any one charger to
our heads and not our hearts all of your
hard work
and expressions of kindness will be
remembered and properly acknowledged at
a less stressful time
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]